[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques pour
notre pays et sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation alors aujourd'hui nous
nous penchons sur la guerre au sahel le
g5 sahel date de février 2014 et
regroupe 5 et à la mauritanie le mali le
burkina faso le niger et le tchad
le g5 a été conçu pour aider au
développement économique
mais il a également une composante
militaire qui est devenu extrêmement
importante avec le temps malgré l'appui
de la france
une addition de faiblesse ne fait pas
une force comme on a pu le constater les
conclusions du sommet du g 5 salles le
13 janvier à pau qui regroupe les cinq
chefs d'état et le président de la
république française ont reconnu le rôle
essentiel de l'armée française est la
conséquence a été une augmentation de
600 hommes à l'opération barkan qui a
été décidé en commun mais cette décision
n'apporte pas de solutions véritables à
la dégradation régulière de la situation
sur place
quelle que soit la qualité expertise
indéniable de nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant évoqué
commençons par rappeler les débuts de
l'histoire nous sommes en 2007
la fusion des deux groupes terroristes
du gspc groupe salafiste pour la
prédication et le combat et le gia le
groupe islamique armé qui se battent
contre l'armée et la police algérienne
depuis 15 ans donne naissance à aqmi qui
signifie al qaïda au maghreb islamique
le quart à peu près le quart de ce
groupe terroriste créée par abdel malek
droukdel ceux qui revendent à peu près
200 hommes va progressivement descendre
sous la pression de l'armée algérienne
vers la frontière sud de l'algérie
puisse installer au nord mali et ils
vont informer 2 katiba une katiba c'est
pour certains appellent ça une compagnie
militaire
pour d'autres le camp des la traduction
réelle c'est quand des combattants c'est
katiba d'al son double yade à deux il ya
celle d'abou zaid qui est très connue
parce que il a une petite barbe rousse
donc c'était un arabe à barberousse et
celle de mokhtar belmokhtar qui est
également un personnage célèbre dans la
région parce qu'on l'appelait monsieur
marlboro pourquoi monsieur marlboro
c'est parce qu'il a passé toute sa vie
avant de devenir terroriste à faire du
trafic de cigarettes entre la mauritanie
le mali le niger et le tchad pour se
financer
c'est katiba vont multiplier les prises
d'otages contre rançon bien entendu et
vont faire connaître par des raids
contre des installations militaires ou
civils souvenez-vous de la sphère des la
menace par exemple attaque de la zone
pétrolière en algérie lors de l'autre
côté du maghreb la mort du président
kadhafi en 2011 près de misrata va
provoquer le retour au tchad au niger et
surtout au mali parce que ces deux là
ont ils venaient prioritairement aux
majoritairement des mercenaires touaregs
qui assurait sa sécurité
or ces gens là sont des combattants très
efficace qui vont récupérer avant de
partir de libye
la plus grande partie du matériel
militaire stockées dans les entrepôts
libyen
ils vont arriver ils vont revenir dans
leur pays d'origine et en particulier
pour les maliens avec l'objectif de
conquérir au mieux leur indépendance ou
pire leur autonomie ce qu'il faut noter
c'est qu'ils sont certes musulman mais
leur culture traditionnelle donne un
rôle très important aux femmes
nous sommes dans un régime de matriarcat
et ceci depuis des millénaires et ceci
dès éloigne bien entendu des salafistes
et également de l'autre populations
nomades locales les peuls qui se sont
implantés progressivement dans les cinq
derniers siècles par le djihad
évoquons maintenant le tirage le sahel
est une zone très sèche et très pauvres
qui va de l'atlantique à la mer rouge
elle est peuplée nomades arabes touareg
et peul qui dans le temps suivaient
leurs troupeaux et se regrouper autour
des points d'eau parce qu'on ne pouvait
vivre qu'à partir du moment où on était
proche d'un point d'eau pour améliorer
la situation
les guerriers les hommes faisait
régulièrement des raids au sud pour
s'approprier de la nourriture des
troupeaux ou encore des femmes et des
hommes qui les exploitaient comme
esclaves
on les appelait à l'époque les haratines
c'est une tradition donc séculaire qui
reste ancré dans la mémoire des
populations du sud qui ont beaucoup
souffert et qui redoutent les peuples
nomades du nord aujourd'hui à compter de
l'élevage qui continue d'être une
activité importante
on a aussi des exploitations minières
comme les mines d'uranium d'arlit par
exemple un qui appartiennent vous savez
à une société française et une
production agricole qui est insuffisante
par rapport à ce besoin de cette
population qui vit en permanence avec
une yom durer une à la limite de la
famine dans cette zone qu'on appelle
l'azawad tout le monde fait du troc
s'il n'y a pas d'argent et la
contrebande et donc l'acte i mean
activité très importante une activité de
masse dans laquelle le 4 4 a remplacé le
chameau ont permettant de couvrir des
distances de plus de 500 kilomètres en
une nuit on atteint 500 600 km ce qui
fait que on se déplace très vite dans
toute la zone
en 2012 les groupes terroristes et
indépendantistes comprenant les touareg
qui étaient revenus de libye ont foncé
sur bamako capitale du mali
ils ont profité de la faiblesse de
l'armée malienne qui était composé de
gens du sud qui ont beaucoup de qualités
mais dans la qualité guerrière n'est pas
la vertu première
c'est pourquoi à la demande du président
malien qui à l'époque s'appelait amadou
touré
l'armée française est intervenue dans le
cadre de l'opération serval avec l'aide
des troupes tchadiennes qui sont venus
en renfort et cette action de contre
guérilla qui était ponctuelle et très
légère faso katiba djihadistes puisque
le but 1 était bien entendu de les
bloquer mais également il est le but
était de d'arrêter les filières vers la
libye par lequel passait tous les
trafics et servent à la été on peut le
dire un succès total de nos âmes
d'autre part les indépendantistes se
sont ralliés un processus d'autonomie de
la zone nord sont passés de
l'indépendance à l'autonomie à un accord
négocié à alger en 2015 entre la
république du mali
les groupes indépendantistes du nord et
la coordination des mouvements de
l'azawad qui représentaient la majorité
du peuple touareg
alors comme le dit le général bentégeat
ancien chef d'état major français des
armées
on est alors passé avec l'opération
barkan à une guerre de coaliser dans un
environnement globalement hostile qui a
pour objectif de sécuriser l'ensemble de
la zone on a donc complètement basculer
d'une guerre d'intervention rapide et
courtes à autre chose que peuvent faire
un peu plus de 5000 militaires français
à l'efficacité certes reconnu sur une
zone aussi vaste puisqu'elle fait à peu
près cinq fois la france même renforcé
par cinq mille soldats fournis par les
pays du g5 saleh
c'est là où les problèmes ont commencé
mais qui ne sont pas près de se terminer
d'abord en france où l'on voit monter
l'inquiétude et l'incompréhension de nos
concitoyens sur l'utilité de notre
participation
il faut dire que dans cette zone sans
cesse élargie les attentats se
multiplient les communautés et scheer et
nous avons des morts sur place
justement par leur action les militaires
français empêchent les populations de
trafic et ce qui a eu pour effet à côté
des arabes d'aqmi et des touareg dans le
sahel dinh d'avoir les trafiquants poehl
qui se sont regroupés dans un groupe
terroriste qu'on appelle le mou zhao
ainsi en dehors des vrais jihadistes
keith restent très minoritaires
tous les autres selon l'heure et le
moment bien ils peuvent être djihadistes
trafiquants ou commerçants ce qui rend
extrêmement difficile de gérer le
problème des résultats l'opinion
publique régionale se plaint de la
présence française qui est considéré
comme colonialiste parce qu'elle gêne
dans tout ce qu'on vient d'évoquer à
l'évidence la solution n'est donc pas
militaire mais politique
la paix durable ne peut résulter que
d'une action résolue sur les facteurs
politiques et sociaux du conflit
pour arrêter la guerre il faut procéder
comme au niger après le premier conflit
touareg des années 90 qui était menée
par un personnage chez l'ex appelé mano
dayak un chef touareg s'appeler manaudou
il faut développer un plan
d'investissement pour mettre en valeur
le nord avec l'aide des groupes
étrangers qui exploite les mines ou des
gisements ce qui est parfaitement
possible
ceci permettra de mieux intégrer les
populations touareg epl d'incorporer les
groupes armés dans l'armée régulière et
développer un sentiment de cohésion
nationale qui est indispensable parce
qu'il faut retrouver une entité un
esprit d'état quand on regarde ce qui
s'est passé au niger justement après
cette guerre
aujourd'hui il y à sept ministres
touareg plus le chef d'état major des
armées en iran exactement dans l'esprit
des accords d'alger
au burkina faso les mots petits qui sont
l'ethnie au pouvoir commencent à se
rendre compte qu'il faudra appliquer la
même politique que celle qu'on a vue au
niger
face à la pression des populations du
nord qu'ils contrôlent déjà un tiers du
territoire
et c'est d'autant plus important que sur
le plan militaire le corps d'élite de
l'armée burkinabé la garde
présidentielle a été décapité suite à la
tentative de coup d'état 2015 certes
pour les nigériens on voit bien qu'ils
subissent des attaques meurtrières
mais au delà de la frontière libyenne
l'essentiel de l'aide des actions de
guerre se concentre dans la zone des
trois frontières et sont menées
essentiellement par des groupes venus du
mali d'où la nécessité absolue de
s'intéresser au mali la clé du sahel
c'est le mali et les déclarations
récentes des politiques des spécialistes
des experts des militaires montre bien
que nous sommes face à une
incompréhension totale entre les
différents acteurs
l'état malien voudrait que l'on élimine
les touareg ennemi héréditaire des
populations du sud le même état ne se
préoccupe pas du tout des trafiquants
qui font vivre l'économie souterraine et
ne sont pas autonomistes la france par
contre c'est qu'il faut une autonomie
partielle du nord du pays que le
président malien refuse au nom de la
majorité de sa population
on peut ajouter que tout ceci est en
train de se compliquer par un autre
phénomène inquiétant
après la guinée-bissau le mali est en
train de devenir progressivement un
narco état dans lequel les trafiquants
achète les consciences et les votes
il utilise les djihadistes et d'autres
aussi d'ailleurs pour faire circuler la
drogue vers les pays du nord vers la
méditerranée par des filières qui
servent aussi pour les cigarettes pour
les produits pharmaceutiques et ne
l'oublions pas pour les migrants et ceci
explique sans doute l'installation de
certaines personnalités du milieu des
gens qu'on a vu arriver par exemple du
gabon et qu'on a vu arriver d'autres
pays d'afrique qui sont installés sur
place parce que ça devient le coeur
d'une zone de trafic très important et
je dirais presque intercontinentaux
parce que pour la drogue
les produits viennent d'amérique du sud
et d'amérique centrale en conclusion la
clé du succès passe par le croisement de
trois actions indispensables et
complémentaires
en premier lieu il faut rétablir la
sécurité
et ça évidemment c'est le rôle du
militaire des français des militaires
locaux des militaires de la zone du g5 1
pour bloquer la situation empêcher
éradiquer je dirais le djihadisme sur le
plan militaire mais ce n'est pas
suffisant il faut aussi développer
l'économie réelle
sur l'ensemble de chaque pays concerné
de manière équilibrée
il faut que les gens du nord soit aussi
bien traités que les gens du sud et qui
n'est pas la sensation d'être les
oubliés
et dans les différents états et en
particulier au mali
et enfin il faut mettre en place bien
entendu et c'est la suite des deux
autres points que je viens d'évoquer
il faut mettre en place une bonne
gouvernance par des incitations par dz
et part du conseil et pour ceci il faut
des dirigeants qu'une volonté réelle de
changer les choses
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin de très
longue durée comme l'ont connu les
américains en afghanistan ou en irak et
que ceci se termine par une retraite
sans gloire
à bientôt
[Musique]